-Oh, my gosh.
-Is that the fastest --
That's the fastest wardrobe
change I've ever had on a show.
-You are fantastic
and a stunner.
-I'm a professional at it,
actually.
-Yeah, you are actually.
You're really good.
-Quick changes. Very good.
-Can I just say -- Look at this.
Stunning.
-Oh, thank you.
-On the cover of "Vogue."
This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've done over 35 covers
of "Vogue."
-It's crazy.
-How does it feel?
Does it --
-I don't even know.
It's, like, I mean, obviously
an honor and amazing,
but I don't know
how it went by so fast.
It's, like, I remember each one,
like, such a vivid memory
of the day with so many people
that are involved and work
so hard to create each photo.
So it's amazing
that it's been that many.
-I have a photo of you.
This is your first photo
that I think was in "Vogue."
Is this possible?
-Oh, I actually --
-No?
-That's a funny story.
So, I didn't know
what magazine this was in.
I just know my mom had a tear
sheet from it growing up.
And I didn't really know
the story behind it.
And last -- It's a picture of me
on vacation with my family.
I was holding an Eiffel Tower
I just bought
and my little film camera.
And then I saw a photo shoot
going on here,
and I went and stand
in front of the photographer.
See, I'm very interested.
-Yeah, you're like,
"I want to be in the shot."
-And he took a picture.
I was in the shot.
This was in some
French magazine.
And I didn't know the story
behind it.
And then a couple of years ago,
I posted it.
See? Here's my post.
-Yeah.
-"Does anyone know
who shot this editorial?
If anyone can recall. Surreal."
And a photographer that I've
been working with since 2014
at this point was like,
"Gigi, I took that photo
how many years ago."
And now I work with him now
backstage at shows.
-And he had no idea
who you were.
-No idea that he shot me.
No idea we had that connection.
And I know him now as an adult.
It's wild.
-Isn't that cool?
-Yeah, it's really crazy.
-You start off as just a kid
walking around
with an Eiffel Tower,
and then you end up
on the cover of "Vogue."
What are the stickers,
by the way?
-Those stickers are --
So, this is
"Vogue: Netherlands."
My mom's Dutch, so I was
really excited to do this cover,
and I did it with one of my
best friends, Alana O'Herlihy.
And we got to really
creative-direct this shoot
and have a lot of fun with it.
So, these stickers are actually
from a Dutch amusement park
called The Efteling.
And it's a beautiful, kind of
quaint amusement park
in a forest with all these,
like, fairy tales.
And these stickers,
they were flown from Holland
for this shoot.
-You used to go to this park?
-Yes, when I was a kid.
Every summer with --
My aunt and uncle
live across the street.
They had, like, yearly passes.
And it's just
a really special place to me,
and I kind of wanted
to nod to all those memories
and my oma, who passed away.
But we had
really special times there,
and that's, you know,
for all the Dutchies.
They'll get that, for sure,
when they see it.
-I love that.
Congratulations on doing that.
I think it's cool
that you did that.
You do some things where I go,
"Man, Gigi,
don't do these things."
Because you scare me.
-What are they?
-Well, there are photos that
you take that are dangerous.
-Let's see it.
-I'm gonna show you one.
Here's you on a scaffolding.
Are you kidding me?
-Oh, yeah.
-No!
-Yeah.
-The answer is,
"Gigi can't do it. Sorry."
-I'm asked to do
a lot of crazy things.
And, yeah, it just happens.
But my management
and my security,
they always get these calls
from some production teams
that are like --
They're panicking.
They're like, "So we're maybe
gonna have to have Gigi
on a 100-foot thing
hanging in the sky.
Will she do it? If not,
we'll have these options."
I don't say no.
I say yes to everything.
-No. Absolutely not.
-I'm insane. I do it all.
-=That's why you need me
as your manager --
to get in there so you don't --
-No, they tell them like,
"Gigi will go for it."
So, yeah, I always say yes.
-Here's you on the same
scaffolding shoot.
-In the beginning, it's scary,
but then by the end of it...
-You're dancing. Jumping on it.
What's wrong with you?
-I'm in a harness.
I'm in a harness. See?
-No. Either way,
it's still scary.
-It's movie magic.
-It's still scary.
-And stunting.
-[ Laughs ] Stunting.
Can we talk about
"Next in Fashion"? Okay.
-I'm wearing this outfit,
so clearly,
I'm trying to talk about
"Next in Fashion."
-Yes. You're always
the next in fashion.
-Thank you.
-You're cohosting this
with Tan France,
who we love, from "Queer Eye."
-Yes. We love.
-How do you know Tan?
Before the show,
did you know him or no?
-So, I,
like the rest of America,
five years ago --
or the world --
when "Queer Eye" came out,
I was a huge fan.
Fell in love with them...
and was, like, going through
a breakup or something,
like, sitting on my couch
all weekend
near when the show aired.
You know, crying, laughing
all day watching them.
And they just, like,
made my week.
And I saw that Eva Chen,
head of instagram Fashion,
had them in her office --
or had Tan in her office,
specifically.
And I was like, "I'm going to
have to FaceTime him."
So, I FaceTime him. We talk.
And I'm like --
This never happens, by the way.
Like, I'm obsessed with Jimmy.
Like, I consider him one of my
favorite people in the world.
And, like, I was never, like,
a weirdo in this way.
But with Tan for some reason,
I'm like, "Will you come
to my house and have tea
with me right now?"
-Yeah, you've never
invited me over for tea.
-I know! But that's, like,
out of, like --
I'm not trying to, like,
annoy you, you know?
Like, you're clearly busy.
-You would never annoy me.
-So is Tan.
But you know what I'm saying.
-So you call -- you FaceTime
the "Queer Eye" guys.
-So I FaceTime them
and I'm like,
"Do you want to be my friends?"
Pretty much like,
"Please come over."
And we -- They came over.
We, like, had lunch at my house.
We, like, talked, hung out.
It was Antoni, Tan,
and Jonathan that day.
And now Antoni is one of
my best friends, my neighbor.
And obviously,
Tan and I are doing the show.
And it's just, like,
such a special experience.
-Are you loving doing this show?
Because I know you.
You've been a great guest
on the show and a good friend.
But I know that you love
reality competition shows.
-Big fan.
-We've talked about this. Yes.
There was one
you kept telling me.
There was, like, a glass-blowing
show that you loved.
-Oh, I love glass blowing.
I love "LEGO Masters."
-"LEGO Masters" is good, too.
-Yeah. Like, all of them --
obsessed.
But, now, do you like
hosting and judging?
-Love hosting, love judging.
Such a special,
you know, new experience for me,
getting to go to the same studio
every day with the same crew.
You know, it's like
an office job, like you.
And, um --
[ Laughter ]
I'm just trying to be you,
Jimmy.
Okay, so, but anyways --
-It's a good thing.
-No, it's the best.
It's such a nice feeling.
-You're a natural.
You're also --
Not only are you stunning,
but you're also
funny and charming
and interested
in things and people,
and you're a good host.
-And normally, like, in my job,
I think I haven't been
really ever given the time
and the space to, like,
really open up and show myself.
Not on purpose,
for my fashion job.
It's just such a small,
you know, snippet of time
that you're given in those
kind of fashion, more --
-You get to be you.
-Yeah, I get to be me.
And I think I try to be funny.
-Yeah, you are.
-You guys judge for yourself.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Gigi Hadid
in "next in Fashion."
Take a look at this.
-Gi?
-Yeah?
-You want to tell me
how you're feeling?
Should we start with --
Diandre. Thoughts?
-It's really cool. I think
the proportions are spot on.
-Does it feel royal?
-I think it does feel royal.
I think it's hip-hop royalty
for sure.
-Agreed, agreed. Okay.
Megan. It's definitely bold.
And I've got a feeling
a lot of people
are either going to
love it or hate, but --
-That's what I want.
-That's exactly what we want.
-I love this jacket.
I think it's really cool.
So I'm going to be happy
just if it gets done.
-James, I hate to say,
might be in trouble.
-Royal is here, and James is
here, and his look is here.
And he needs to bring
both of those here.
-That's exactly right.
He's here. Bring it in here.
Gigi Hadid!
"Next in Fashion"
premieres Friday on Netflix.
Chase Stokes joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.